So thus far, we've been able to record our sound, and
then print the name of the file where we actually recorded our voice.
At this point,
I want us to consider two scenarios that can cause some trouble going forward.
The first one has to do with our story board, so let me go back to Xcode.
Now we know that we are recording our voice in here in the first scene, or
in Record Sounds View Controller.
We also know that we need that recorded file in here,
in the second scene, or in Play Sounds View Controller.
Right now, when we hit this Stop button,
we move very promptly form this first scene, to the second scene.
Do you think we will need to pass the audio file from
the first scene to the second scene?
If so, how would we go about doing that?
So here is the first scenario that we need to think deeply about.
The second scenario has to do with recording audio.
Right now the sounds that we are recording, are really short.
About five to ten seconds long.
What do you think will happen if our user records a conversation with
a friend for about five minutes?
I would imagine that it will take our phone some time to process that
audio properly.
Now picture this.
Our phone is in the middle of processing a really large sound file here in
the first scene,
while we have pushed the stop button and moved on to the second scene, and
already started to play the audio that hasn't fully finished recording yet.
That could cause some troubles.
So then the question is,
how will we know that the phone has successfully finished recording in
the first scene, before we play that audio in the second scene?
Now, I want you to think about both of these scenarios, and
then write down your reflections in these boxes,
on how you would go about solving both of these issues.